if all is not that complicated really
you either work with a team of hunters
using your array of abilities to track
and kill a monster or you stalk wildlife
and hunt humans and groffle everyone
down with glee as the monster and yet
somehow someway people manage to
absolutely blow it I'm not talking about
matches we were just outclassed by
better players I'm talking about matches
that are doomed from the start because
some chucklehead medic thinks he's there
to land 360 noscope headshots and leaves
his med gun packs in his checked luggage
ah you don't want to be that guy you
don't even want to play with that guy so
consider this a PSA aimed at eliminating
as many of the vet guys as possible
here's how to not suck at evolve the
first tip is as fundamental to
class-based multiplayer games as an
internet connection and electricity know
your role look at this character select
screen right here see there's four
things your hunters can do the thing on
the right is the class ability that
every one of your ilk can do and it's
valuable it is
but bozos are born in weapons selections
so that's what you need to sort out
quickly rank your priorities by asking
yourself two questions what class am i
playing and which one of these weapons
is the most that if I'm playing the
support then I should do the support
iasts thing I can Hanks shield projector
buckets turrets Cabot's damage amplifier
boom if there's something you can do
that no one else can do there's your
number one make number two your damage
dealer unless your assault and then
everything is your damage dealer number
three is what's left use the number one
thing seventy percent of the time the
number two thing twenty percent of the
time and the number three thing ten
percent of the time and you'll be well
on your way to not being a dire
disappointment to your friends loved
ones neighbors and society at large
here's another tip stay together look we
all know Lazarus is super creepy but
wouldn't you rather die near the skeezy
necro medic then across the map from him
you're a team and there's no just going
to run over here real quick BRB in team
Chompy boulders
got sized crocodiles and demonic plant
lips are just some of the things waiting
to grab onto you and not let go unless
your teammate shoot them
fortunately the big red health bars over
their heads make your buddies really
easy to follow and if you get super
discombobulated like you ran to the
bathroom banged your head on the
radiator and somehow filled your
apartment with a thick fog use the map
Buckshot no excuses and talk get on your
dang old headset and dangled say words
to your dang ol teammates I'll lead
ain't gonna bite I swear the more
technology brings us together the more
it separates us you know what I
understand that sometimes you happen to
drop a brick on your headset while your
mortaring up your windows to protect
yourself from peeping toms and sunlight
and hexes so if you can't get on chat
use waypoints to communicate it's the
digital equivalent of crudely jabbing
your finger in a direction and grunting
but it's better than nothing so you've
got your arsenal prioritized and you're
rolling with your team and talking and
pointing and pursuing the monster
briskly when what should appear around
the corner what a big monster sweet kill
it be able to do 50 of you leave randos
alone unless it has a little elite icon
above it and your whole crew is down to
kill it just fly on by because a it
wastes your time and lets the monster
get further away be the really big
fellas can incapacitate you and brand
you with that hester prynne ian mark of
shame and see anything you kill turns
into a free buffet for the monster if it
circles back around just live and let
live and except for Reavers buck reapers
in evolve your mobility is as important
as your aim so pay attention to your jet
pack fuel leap from heights to fly
further use the DoubleTap boost to
pursuit faster and don't be afraid to
spend some battle time just running
on the ground saving your jetpack juice
for when you really need it like evading
the monster slathering jobs if your
squad is strong it'll usually be the
monster fleeing you but if your friend
owes start to drop rabbiting from the
scene can help your team live to fight
another day
remember the monster can sniff you out
so don't wait until you're the last one
alive to turn tail wait until you're the
second to last one alive and then have
your only other friend in the world run
in the opposite direction so at least
one of you will make it it's kind of
heartbreaking you know but perhaps
you'll meet again in that radiance
ethereal plane beyond death beyond pain
beyond everything the scummy cargo hold
of a beat-up dropship keep these
elementary tips and I promise you will
not suck it at all at least not as much
as the actual players whose tomfoolery
inspired all of these tips and hey do
you want to not suck is the monster - of
course you do so number one to start
take at least one evasion skill and one
hunting skill Goliath sleep smash gives
you some extra mobility while fire
breath is great for hosing down your
horse sized fred hunt for two and three
meet fray and keep moving around the map
because of tip number two don't engage
the hunters until you are stage two and
have full armor remember you get
stronger during the match and they stay
the same age but your skill level when
you get into a scrap follow tip number
three the order of murder a shion's kill
Hank first because his goddamn shield
generator can basically negate your
attacks if no one is playing Hank kill
the medic if you're in a bad dome
situation kill the trapper and vamoose
fight aggressively when you have armor
and play evasively when you're running
on health alone once you've down to
hunter keep an eye on their prone body
and punish any hunters who come around
to revive them - in cap is golden to
kill divine see now that doesn't sound
so hard does it take these tips to heart
and please share them with a friend
friends don't let friends suck it evolve
you